hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen luca wie kann er schlafen als
fucking hell draußen es ist gerade 19
uhr abends luca schläft wacht gerade von
seinem schnäppchen und zieht sich seine
neuen klamotten das mutige löschen eines
brandes kann das selbstbewusstsein eines
sims erheblicher falls ihr die letzte
folge noch nicht gesehen hat unsere
küche sind angefangen zu brennen und das
löschen des brandes acea so aus dass
unsere komplette küche hier gerade
verbrannt ist die folge verlege ich euch
mal hier wenn ihr euch hier anschauen
wollte sie sind fans über fans kommen
sogar nach dem schönen mittagsschläfchen
jetzt erst mal ein schönes stück von der
torte nehmen mal schauen obwohl das
irgendwie ob das überhaupt noch schmeckt
er mir wurden 1017 die kommentare
geschrieben wie ich beispielsweise mein
haus schilder machen kann oder wie ich
auf diesen fernseher hier drehen kann
ich habe allerdings keinen trick
durchgelesen
wir spielen mal ein bisschen die zeit
vor bis es irgendwie ein bisschen dunkel
ist und dann besuchen wir tatsächlich
gleich mal unsere nachbarn lukas schaut
gerade eine serie und zwar der steht da
wie so ein psychopath alter stehen
halten stehen die kühe und hühner wir
können sogar rausschauen so es ist jetzt
gerade 22 uhr das heißt wir werden jetzt
einfach mal unseren nachbarn hier
besucher da besuchen und ich kann doch
nicht wirklich schon die schwarz dahin
einladen der plan jetzt ist auf jeden
fall mit johnny schwarz zusammen die
nachbarn besucht
ich natürlich hier in meinem gewohnten
outfit und der johnny schwarz wo ist
denn johnny eigentlich wenn ich da
hingehen will an die tür klopfen
willkommen dass ich hier wohl niemand
versuch nummer zwei ich werde ich jetzt
meine anderen nachbarn auf der anderen
seite zusammen mit sondern john schwarz
besuchen und mal schauen ob da jemand da
wurde auch niemand wie so wilder kerl
neben mir wollen ich habe gerade einfach
so in der wildnis diesem steigen hier
gefunden was glaube ich irgendwie ein
diamant stein oder sowas sein könnt ich
habe überhaupt keine ahnung vielleicht
kriegen wir genau so macht man das luca
kommt sofort auf unsere stadt einfach so
eine richtige geisterstadt ist mir kommt
also mein gott dieser stuhl letzten voll
kaputt da geht einfach manchmal schlafe
jetzt erstmal bis der nächste morgen
anbricht und dann schauen wir mal was
der nächste tag so mit sich bringt
welser kingsley der da ist man zwölf
sekunden am schlafen und dann was ist
das für ein mensch kann ich stofftiere
benennen das hier war doch dass ihr
verband sie dann nicht sie einfach mal
baxi und das hier war dort dann bekommt
der antrag gegen den gegner aus dass ein
typischer bob lucassen was machst du das
schon wieder in der küche ich habe ich
gebe ihm keine aufgaben mehr regelt
alles von alleine gerade gesehen dass
bei uns im garten einfach die not steht
kommen wir besuchen wir die jetzt mal
witzig ist auch ich will immer johnny
schwarz aus dass damit wir da hinkommen
soll und da kommt einfach nie wird weil
er mich einfach auch guck mal ich bin
zusammen mit schon nicht schwarz was ist
hier wird etwas kann ich dann mit johnny
kommen erstmal rumblödeln mit johnny das
ist doch johnny leoni angespannt ist
einfach mein bester freund hier die
tollen polizisten wird hier mit ihm ja
dann habe ich mich so hingestellt wurde
ja in meinen bademantel da die gezeigte
schau mal her erledigen dann ja dann hat
sie angefangen zu lachen weil sie fand
dass ich das nicht und dann habe ich
musik gemacht wenn sie aufzumuntern
dinge gedacht ja kommen wenn sie jetzt
nicht mag dann zeige ich dir einfach
mein gesicht dass ich mir ein paar
bücher gekauft und
hat ein gesicht aber echt schön gekommen
schoss sie an sondern wir kaffee trinken
gehen ja ein café ich hasse fliegen
wir sind doch ein richtiges verliebtes
pärchen hier die beiden ich finde die
beiden richtig super die haben die ganze
zeit punkte das ist doch super und es
steigt mittlerweile schon ins grüne
jetzt aber da habe ich jetzt aber
erschreckt hier hat das war witzig er
jetzt alle richtigen gang hier am start
was ist das denn hier wie so guckt sie
mir den job ganz gut und denke das hat
eine mülltonne wenn sie wie ich sie so
mein gott guckt euch diese
inneneinrichtung von denen an die haben
in ihrem haus innen drin einen kleinen
garten wie krank ist das denn da bin ich
jetzt gerade mal wirklich ein paar
sekunden im haus und dann rasten die
darin bei allem respekt ich habe nichts
dagegen wenn man zum spaß hat aber das
ist einfach nur noch pervers und was
läuft er rechts überhaupt im fernsehen
ich bin echt kurz davor hinzuziehen hier
geht wenigstens so die post bei mir
wurde einfach kein mensch er da vorne
tanzt schön deine mutter an johnny
freundet sich mit dem mädel an und luca
luka schläft tatsächlich einfach auf der
couch ich sind einfach alle schlafen an
dieser stelle meine lieben freunde wenn
ihr schon jeder kennt kann ich
eigentlich nur noch das video beenden
wenn durch dieser partie muss gefallen
hat zeigt sie mit einer bewertung bei
40.000 daumen hoch mache ich noch ein
paar nein ich hasse diese daumen hoch
sachen ich mache ihnen noch ein paar hat
es treibt mir weitere tipps in die
kommentare die werde ich mir dann
diesmal vielleicht auch durch lesen oder
auch nicht